their murders have gone unsolved for
decades the faces of victims whose
families have never seen justice but now
answers are coming from a new forensic
technology in terms of being able to
identify suspects
I think it's as valuable and a sort of
groundbreaking as DNA technology was in
the early eighties it's led to dozens of
arrests and suspects on trial if we
didn't have this technology that may
never been solved it's already changing
how police hunt rapists and killers we
actually have the ability to stop
criminals in their tracks but should
questions of ethics and privacy worry us
when solving a cold case crime might
reveal a killer in the family she was
like an old soul she loved old blues
records and she just had a real piece
about her Linda O'Keefe was 11 in July
1973 on the day her sister will never
forget she didn't have her bicycle that
day and at the end of the school day she
called my mom and said mom can you come
and get me and she said Linda I'm really
busy can you just walk home and she said
Oh mom please and she was crying since
no just just walk home so she didn't
come home
[Music]
starting to get dark and so my dad and I
got in the family cars and started
driving around the school in the
neighborhood and just looking and
calling her friends houses now she's not
here and it got dark so my parents
called the police the next morning there
were some people from the University
going down this path and they saw that
the high grasses were sort of crumpled
and so that's what they found her
[Music]
I've had me later just because I saw
that my parents were so devastated you
known as a parent and a grandparent
myself I I cannot imagine how
devastating that would be I mean I lost
a sister and that's terrible thing but
as a parent it just like I can't
comprehend how that how awful that would
be this story came out that a woman
allegedly saw my sister talking to a man
in a ban on the boulevard that she would
have taken on her walk home and so
everywhere we went
you know we'd go for a drive within the
family and if we saw a turquoise van my
father would chase it for miles on the
road because he was convinced that that
was the guy but years would pass and
Linda's murder would become a cold case
until 46 years after she died when I got
the call from the detective and he said
he was sitting down and I said yes and
he said well I wanted to let you know I
just arrested the man in Colorado
Springs this morning and they said Wow
James Alan Neal a 72 year old
grandfather has been charged with
Linda's murder her case one of dozens
many dating back decades seeing a
breakthrough thanks to a new forensic
technique what's called genetic
genealogy potentially changing
crime-fighting forever now your DNA is
ready for transport open up the
biohazard bag and place the tube inside
at its heart is the explosion in the
number of people testing their own DNA
for family history research while these
companies don't share the data hundreds
of thousands of their customers have
uploading it to a public genealogy
website called Jed match there all that
information has become investigative
gold thanks to Cece more familiar to
Americans as a DNA detective on TV now
the pioneer with a forensic science
company of finding matches between crime
scene DNA and all that family data
online we are taking
a of an unknown person or a person with
unknown biological parents and we're
looking at who shares DNA with that
person our people second cousins third
cousins fourth cousins and so we're
using the family trees of people who
share DNA with that person of unknown
identity or heritage and building their
family trees and once we're building the
family trees of the people sharing DNA
with the unknown suspect then we can
reverse-engineer their own family tree
and so building forward in time we're
looking for somebody in the right place
at the right time right gender right
circumstances to potentially be that
person of interest it was that process
that led police to the most high-profile
arrests so far the alleged Golden State
killer Joseph D Angelo genetic genealogy
pointed detectives in the direction of
the former police officer they then
obtained his DNA directly he's been
charged with a dozen murders on the
sheriff's wall in Snohomish County in
Washington State they put up a deck of
cards of unsolved murders among them
Tonya van cauwenberghe and Jay Cooke a
Canadian couple killed on a work trip
together that was in 1987 it remained a
mystery for decades 25 until William
Talbot was charged and went on trial
Tolbert had been identified by CC more
DNA he'd left at the scene matched two
people on Jed match so each of them
shared around 3% of their DNA that means
that they would most likely share
great-grandparents by picking through
the family trees Talbot emerged as a
suspect and the police did the rest
Tanya's brother John attended every day
of the trial I would still remember the
phone call from detective sharp I mean
it sho went down my spine I mean who's
you know they had been keeping me
somewhat informed as they were getting
closer and but you know it was really
just that final moment of truth like
they've actually got this guy under
harassed you know always like it was
just surreal I mean you know waiting for
anything 31 years you know all of a
sudden here that it's
is just you know it was it was great
over the years you know I certainly felt
that the chance of an arrest and was was
getting last for sure but I never gave
up hope
Talbots trial was the first of someone
arrested using genetic genealogy he
denied murder the guilty verdict for
police confirming this as potentially
game-changing it's almost the same as if
there was an eyewitness who saw that
suspect driving the vehicle that was
involved in the crime very somewhere for
police the genetic genealogy leads us
down the right path to identify somebody
and then we use the regular processes in
place but to put there by the criminal
justice system I'm getting search
warrants establishing probable cause in
order then to make an arrest
and Talbots conviction is a significant
moment for genetic genealogy to have
genetic genealogy officially vetted in a
court of law is a huge step forward the
fact it wasn't even challenged by the
defense says a lot about our stance that
this is a tip this is lead generation
and I think is going to make a big
difference for those agencies that were
staying on the sidelines waiting to see
the outcome of the first trial after a
career as a police forensic investigator
Mahal and area now advises on DNA
evidence in trials at a moment of rapid
change I think we might want to slow
down a little bit so we don't ruin it
for the future we need to have better
regulations not just for some you know
just pure ethics or to feel good but we
want more and more people to put their
DNA in the database that question of
privacy is one that keeps cropping up
and even whether constitutional rights
are being violated it's not a question
of oh I shouldn't be scared to put my
DNA in the database if I didn't do
anything the thing is I might implicate
relatives of mine but not close
relatives people who are third cousins
who I don't even know so now it's not
like a third party consent issue like if
you're talking about a search warrant
it's a
earth party consent because I didn't put
my DNA in there but one of my relatives
did I recognized the concerns about
privacy I am NOT personally concerned
about the right to privacy of a suspect
who has perpetrated a really violent
crime against innocent people but when
DNA can even generate an image of a
potential suspect the possibilities are
endless could they scan through millions
of pictures on social media for example
or use facial recognition technology to
identify possible persons of interest
those legal questions will have to be
answered privacy there's always this
what constitutes going too far you know
and we often we often say you know
there's a creepy factor when things are
too creepy than policy might step in or
public demand might step in and hear
this this is something where people have
been calling for regulators and Congress
to step in and fashion a solution in an
age where we have data aggregation where
we where privacy is becoming really a
myth we're exposing all of our most
intimate information all the time to at
least one third party often a private
company and and so the Supreme Court is
starting to grapple with this reality
this is like the timeline she sent me of
like that night that she died I got some
messages on Facebook some message
requests and people several people were
asking me if I was related to anybody
way with the last name burns in Iowa I
found out that there's a murder case
that was 39 years old and a search
warrant had been released that had my
name in it because the DNA that I
uploaded to a website this last summer
was I used to find a guy that was
suspected of murder brandy Jennings had
no idea her family history research had
led police hundreds of miles away to
Jere burns now suspected of the murder
of Michelle Martin Co it feels really
great I mean I wish I could have done it
before the parents died they're both
deceased but you know her sister is
still alive and at least she got some
closure on it the prospect of more
stories like Brandy's is now
threat Jed match has changed its
settings requiring users to opt in to
sharing their data potentially limiting
the number of possible matches it may
only be a temporary hitch for a
technology with enormous potential where
do you see the big advance coming in in
the use of this technology
I think utilizing genetic geneology
earlier in the investigation in active
cases is where it can be the most
powerful and have the most impact and
that is because then we actually have
the ability to stop criminals in their
tracks there's no need to have an active
serial killer or serial rapist out there
you know not being identified right if
we can stop people from being victimized
in the first place then that is where
this technology and this new revolution
and crime solving is really gonna make
the biggest difference and in the case
of all of those unsolved murders an
estimated quarter of a million in the US
we've been working with families for
decades and not been able to provide
answers to them we know how their family
members died and we know where they
spent the last few moments on the earth
we don't know who did it and it's so
frustrating not to be able to provide
that sense of justice and I think the
most satisfying part of this technology
being able to now finally identify some
suspects is to come back to the families
and say we think we have a break in this
case families of those like Linda
O'Keefe well I've said in the past that
I got closer to the neck sting when they
found her body and so this is just an
additional level of closure if we didn't
have this genealogy technology that para
bond has come up with it may never been
solved I'm grateful to happened you know
in my lifetime
we all deserve mercy but I believe that
justice will be served in this case